bob was incredibly respected in the
comedy and acting world he was one of
the funniest people ever but what i
really remember about him is his energy
his warmth and uh his outgoing just love
that he had for people and he was always
reaching out late comedian bob saget had
a tight bond with ben stiller and his
family especially his parents anne mira
and jerry stiller he loved my parents my
parents loved him over the years they
were so close that bob emceed anne's
memorial in 2015. ben's sister amy
stiller shared this photo of the late
actor at the service as a tribute when
he died in the caption amy says the
stillers specifically chose bob for the
honor and were captivated by his
kindness and warmth when i lost both my
parents he was all he was there for our
family that's what i take away is the
heart that he had and the way he touched
so many people which i think you felt
when when we lost him
but just a genuinely uh good person
e.t caught up with ben and adam scott
while promoting their new apple tv plus
series severance ben directs while adam
is one of the stars petey
is no longer with this company i'm sorry
mark you guys are one of my favorite
office friendships what happened do i
know you my name's petey i'm from work
so we're friends
i'm your best friend
nothing
is what they say
i used to think it would take a monster
to put someone in a place like that
office
especially if the person was himself
patricia arquette and christopher walken
also star in the mystery thriller series
mark is someone in the outside world and
not aware of what his job is and then at
work he has no idea who he is or what
his life is like in the outside world in
the show memories of their personal and
professional lives are severed which
begs the question if they wish they
could do that in real life as an actor
it's kind of hard to
separate work and life because
like it's not like i can put down my
briefcase and and go out into the world
you're kind of constantly reminded of
what you do for a living and who you are
if you're at all recognizable i
certainly see the advantages and i
certainly understand why my character in
the show wants to do this is just so he
doesn't have to
feel anything for eight hours a day it's
it's understandable but it it seems a
little dicey to me it'd be weird not to
know a whole section of your life that's
happening
um
but uh
also i think um it would the part of
your life at the work part would become
so um simple and straightforward because
you wouldn't have any other baggage
there
but if you're a creative person an actor
or filmmaker or you know using any part
of yourself and your work then it would
be kind of hard to draw and experience
because you wouldn't have any dirt that
you you know
so that's i don't know if it would be
practical for uh for a creative person